alors on l'appelle le cabinet des
dépêches c'était une pièce secrète en
plein coeur du château de versailles
connu seulement de lui 15 et de
quelques-uns de ses fidèles
il lui servait de centre de
renseignements c'est là qu'arrive et les
nouvelles confidentielles en provenance
de toute l'europe
ce cabinet avait été oubliée il vient
d'être restaurée gérard dalmaz et alain
poirier vous invite à le visiter fermé à
tout le monde sauf louis caser quelques
fidèles
le cabinet des dépêches au milieu des
appartements du souverain est restée
ignorée des milliers de courtisans
versaillais ces quelques mètres carrés
ont servi de coulisses à la politique
européenne du roi de 1735 à 1774 sa mort
depuis le cabinet se dégradent est
tristement désormais cette pièce secrète
ne l'est plus depuis peu elle est
ouverte aux centaines de milliers de
visiteurs
le cabinet a retrouvé sa splendeur
d'antan après dix mois de restauration
par huit corps de métiers 3 millions de
travaux offert par le mécénat chronopost
louis 15 intelligent mais soupçonneux
lancer des gociations au culte grâce à
sa création des premiers services
secrets français avec un réseau de
chauveau joueurs sélectionnés le
monarque tisse sa toile parallèle à
l'abri des regards et des oreilles
indiscrets ici dans ce repaire pourtant
le succès ne court-on pas toujours les
manoeuvres officieuse
c'est ici dans cette pièce qu'il a
élaborée notamment ceux qu'on appelait
le secret du voix c'est-à-dire sa
diplomatie secrète qui a consisté à
essayer de porter un prince français sur
le trône de pologne c'était très
important ça a échoué
ensuite on a préparé dans cette pièce la
revanche sur l'angleterre après la
désastreuse guerre de sept ans et donc
tout cela ne pouvait pas relevé la
diplomatie officielle bien sûr il
fallait que ce soit fait par des agents
secrets harrouard piètre stratège mais
un cabinet efficace notamment avec ce
fameux chevaliers des eaux les dossiers
brûlants sont mises à jour et le système
du chiffre est sans cesse perfectionnés
pour les lettres codées laissé à sa
propre initiative par louis saez
l'équipe des james bond de l'époque se
vengera de l'angleterre
en poussant la fayette sur le devant de
la scène de l'indépendance américaine
louis 15 tenait fermement à ceux reçus
ses proches n'ont pas réussi à percer le
secret des lieux même ses maîtresses
comme la pompadour qui se mêlaient
pourtant de tous aurait bien voulu
savoir ce qui se tramait chez leurs
ouailles à la môme et elle était le bon
plaisir de lui le bienvenu mais le
cabinet des dépêches était fermée à
double tour